ALL RIGHT. AND
I MISTER ALSO WANTED TO GO
FIRST BUT I DO NOT I HAD ASKED
THE FIRST BUT I DON'T SEE HER
SO. WELCOME TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NOTICING THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM. WE WILL BE AGAIN TODAY
AS A- SUBCOMMITTEE. THANK YOU
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL OR
SERVING ON THE COMMITTEE TODAY
WE HAVE SEVENTY FOUR BILLS TO
CONSIDER BEFORE WE BEGAN JUST A
COUPLE THINGS OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
KEEPING PHYSICAL DISTANCE HERE
WE'VE LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AVAILABLE IN THE GALLERY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM PLEASE
KEEP YOUR MASKS ON MASTER
REQUIRED BY BOTH THE PUBLIC AS
WELL AS MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE
TODAY. STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SEEN SIXTY MORE. AND PLEASE IF
YOU'VE TESTIFIED AND FINISH.
EITHER LEAVE THE ROOM ARE
ENSURE YOU GO DIRECTLY BACK TO
YOUR SEAT. WE WILL NOT HAVE THE
STATIONS OUTSIDE TODAY BECAUSE
OF THE HEAT. WE WILL HAVE DIAL
IN WITNESSES WEALTHY IS A
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY. AND THE TESTIMONY
HAS BEEN PREDETERMINED ON WHO
WILL TESTIFY IN ACTUAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- AND
ACTIVE LISTENING GOING ON
BEHIND. US BEYOND THAT IT WILL
JUST BE PEOPLE CALLING IN TO
SAY THEY SUPPORT OR OPPOSE WITH
NO TESTIMONY. IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION DO NOT
CALL BEFORE THAT. BECAUSE IT
GETS CONFUSING. IF YOU HAVE A
BILL THAT THE PRESENTATION IS
WAIVED ON IT BECAUSE THE
SUSPENSE FILE- YOU MAY REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU
CAN DO THAT BY SIMPLY EMAILING
THAT THE COMMITTEE OR YOU CAN
AT THE VERY END- STATE YOUR
NAME AND FILL IN THE POSITION.
ON IT. OF PLEASE MUTE
BACKGROUND NOISES IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN ON THE PHONE AND
MAKE SURE YOU ARE CALLING IN
ABOUT THE RIGHT BILL. IF YOU
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL OUR COMMITTEE LINE WHICH
IS 916-319-2081 AND MY STAFF
WILL ATTEMPT TO HELP YOU. ON
THE PHONE TODAY OR- RATHER IN
THE BACKGROUND WE ALSO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PRESENT FINANCES PERSPECTIVE.
WE ALWAYS ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
COMMITTEES EMAIL SYSTEM AND
THROUGH THE POSTAL SERVICE IF
IT'S STILL OPERATING AS
DESCRIBED ON APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS THAT ARE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT. I THINK WE
CAN ACTUALLY KALRA AND
SECRETARY. GONZALEZ PRESIDENT
BIGELOW MARKON. BLOOM BONTA
CALDERON ZERO CHAO DALY D.
EGGMAN ON APRIL RCS YOU FOR
YOURS BURKE. READ VOEPEL
REPUBLICAN BACONSKY. ALL RIGHT
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM AND WITH
THAT WE WILL BEGIN- WITH MR
ARCHULETA YOU ARE PRESENTING
ONLY ON SB FOUR EIGHTY CORRECT
IN THAT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CORREO IN A
SECOND BY DOCTOR EGGMAN. READ
AGAIN YOU MAY. PROBABLY ABOUT.
THANK YOU MANAGER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT THE SENATE BILL
FOR EIGHTY. SENATE BILL FOUR
EIGHTY WILL PROHIBIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM
AUTHORIZING THEIR OFFICERS TO
WEAR UNIFORMS THAT ARE COMMON
FLIES OR SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
TO THOSE OF THE UNITED STATES
ARMED FORCES. OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS A NUMBER OF PHOTOS AND
VIDEOS HAVE CIRCULATED SHOWING
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT PROTESTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WITH SOME
OFFICERS WEARING HEAD TO TOE
CAMOUFLAGE UNIFORMS. FOR THE
AVERAGE CITIZEN THESE UNIFORMS
BEARS SUCH A STRIKING
RESEMBLANCE TO THOSE WORN BY
OUR MILITARY THAT MANY HAVE
TROUBLE TELLING THE TWO GROUPS
APART. THIS IS WRONG. OUR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY SHOULD
NOT LOOK LIKE ARMED FORCES.
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY WILL
ENSURE THAT THIS CONFUSION DOES
NOT HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA BY
BANNING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES FROM AUTHORIZING THE
USE OF COMMERCE CLAUSE AND BY
ENSURING LAW ENFORCEMENT
UNIFORMS ARE PROPERLY LABELED.
THIS BILL IS ESTIMATED TO
RESULT IN RELATIVELY MINOR COST
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. STATED WITNESSES AT THAT
THAT'S THE TWO MINUTE WITNESS
FOR SB FOUR EIGHTY THAT WE WILL
OPEN IT UP- FIRST IN THE
GALLERY IF THERE'S ANY BUT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE GALLERY.
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONES-
THE OPERATOR IS THERE TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR EIGHTY. SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO THANK
YOU. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. GREAT AM I ARE THERE
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR EIGHTY
C. NINE WILL GO TO THE PHONES
IS THERE ANY COLORS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR EIGHTY.
OKAY ONE MOMENT MA'AM I NEED TO.
FIX ONE THING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE ONE SECOND.
MMHM.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I HAD A
TECHNICAL ISSUE AND WE'LL GO
ARE YOU WERE SO READY FOR THE
FALL YES WE ARE READY FOR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR
EIGHTY. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOME
THAT ARE QUEUED UP HERE THAT
WERE IN SUPPORT AND THAT- I WAS
HAVING A TECHNICAL ISSUE I
APOLOGIZE FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE. EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOU ARE
OPEN. WHITE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I KNOW RESPONSIBLE TO
MOVE ON TO LIVE. ONE ZERO NINE
ONE ZERO NINE. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE ZERO NINE. SIX
OF ONLINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU BY. ONE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING BRANDED UP ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF
BALLOT IN THE WEAPONS REPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANDAT THE TIME TO SHOW. YOUR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO. AND WE'RE
GETTING A COUPLE QUEUEING UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE FORTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY ONE FORTY
TWO YOU ARE OPEN. ONE FORTY TWO
OR LONG AGO. THERE ARE I'M
AGAINST A BAD. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE I'M
AGAINST THE SB. NINE THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME MEDICARE THANK YOU
OKAY- THANK YOU FOR PEOPLE
WATCHING AT HOME IF WE CAN A
THIS IS WHAT. I WANT YOU TO DO.
I WANT TO THE ONLY CALL IN WHEN
WE'RE ON THE BILL THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO CALL ABOUT SO LET'S
LISTEN TO THE BILL AND THE
AUTHOR AND THEN YOU CAN CALL
IN. AND MAKE SURE WHEN YOU CALL
YOU STATE YOUR NAME ANDYOUR
POSITION. ON THAT BILL- AND
THAT'S IT SO. AGAIN IF WE CAN
TRY TO ADHERE TO THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THOSE OPPOSITIONS WERE
FOR DIFFERENT BILL. WITHOUT
FAIL WILL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND UPPER- APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS THIS IS MILLION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE HAVE
NO POSITION ON THIS BILL- WE
KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DO NOT ANTICIPATE A
FISCAL IMPACT FROM THIS BILL.
THIS BILL MAY CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BUT WE
WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT THE COSTS
WOULD LIKELY BE MINOR IF THERE
IS. THANK YOU. SCENE NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BECAUSE MR ARCHULETA MANAGER
WITH GERMAN THANK YOU AND I ASK
FOR YOUR BY BOAT. THANK YOU
WITH THAT IT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH MISS PETRI
NORRIS VOTING NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHIRLA. SENATOR DICK
GRASSO. NOW FOR PEOPLE AT HOME
SENATOR DRAW SO IT IS GOING TO
BE. PRESENTING ONLY ON S. B.
ONE TWO NINE ZERO SB ONE TWO
NINE ZERO IS THE ONLY BILL
SHE'S PRESENTING ON SO IF YOU
WANT TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION ONLY FOUR S. B.
ONE TWO NINE ZERO NOW IS THE
TIME TO CALL IN AND OPERATE ALL
GO TO AFTER SHE PRESENTS AT
BILL. THIS ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. IT'S MOVED- BY
DOCTOR QUIRK IN A SECOND
PERMITS CARILLO MR AWESOME.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- TODAY I AM
WAIVING PRESENTATION FOR SB
NINE ELEVEN ELEVEN AND THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE I'M PRESENTING ON
IS B. TWELVE NINETY. TWELVE
NINETY SB TWELVE NINETY WILL
AND COLLECTION OF APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
REMAINING IN OUTSTANDING
JUVENILE FEES ASSESSED PRIOR TO
THE PASSAGE OF S. B. ONE NINETY
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR SEVEN
COUNTIES SANDIEGO ORANGE
STANISLAUS RIVERSIDE MADERA
HUMBLED AND LATE. HAVE
INDIVIDUALLY PAUSE OR IN THE
COLLECTION OF OVER SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN OUTSTANDING
JUVENILE FEES. THESE FEES ARE
DOCUMENTED TO HAVE COLLECTION
RATES AS LOW AS ONE PERCENT.
AND COUNTIES OFTEN SPEND MORE
ON THE EFFORTS TO COLLECT THESE
DEBTS THEMSELVES THEN THEY
ACTUALLY RECEIVED FROM
COLLECTING BUT THAT. SB TWELVE
NINETY WILL CAUSE NO
SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE STATE
AND WILL PROVIDE RELIEF TO OVER
SEVENTY THOUSAND FAMILIES. THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT- I
HAVE AVAILABLE TRANSIT TO ADD
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. ARE YOU
PEOPLE FROM UC BERKELEY POLICY
ADVOCACY CENTER- THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I HEARD YOUR AYE
VOTE. SO IS MYSTICAL AVAILABLE
JUST FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
BUT NO NEED TO TESTIFY THEM.
RIGHT OKAY GREAT WITHOUT THEM
WE DON'T NEED TO GO TO MYSTICAL
ON THE LINE OPERATOR ALL WE
NEED TO DO IS OPEN IT UP TO
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO JUST SIMPLY
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT. FOR SB.
ONE TWO NINE ZERO. AS A YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND OUR FIRST ONE WILL
COME FROM NINE NINETY NINE.
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO PART
BECAUSE- THEY THINK YOU'RE-
THANK YOU VENTURA LINED ONE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. HI KAREN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
FUNDING IS ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION HERE
TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MOVING ALONG WITH A LINE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GREGORY FIDEL WITHIN THE SHIITE
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT. AND WE
DO HAVE ANOTHER PERSON WITH AN
OPERATOR SHOW THEIR SUPPORT ONE
MOMENT FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT AND WILL ALIGN. ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. WHAT WHAT DO YOU
ARE OPEN AND THEY JUST DROPPED.
THEREARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU I SEE NOBODY IN THE GALLERY
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL- AND SUCH WE WILL GO TO
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONES THAT WANT
TO REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION.
TO SB. ONE TWO NINE ZERO.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
ONE ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT MADAM
CHAIR WE DO HAVE ONE
PARTICIPANT. FOR ANYBODY ELSE
GO AND NO ONE ZERO SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION. AND WILL I WON
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MY
TEACHERS APOLOGIES THAT I'M
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT AND I JUST
MISSED THE CUT OFF THIS IS A
PRINTOUT AND YOU'LL BE BURBANK
HOUSING OUT OF CINEMA AND NAPA
COUNTY. IT'S YEAH. AND THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME AND HERE
ARE EIGHTEEN NOBODY IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT HAS
NO POSITION ON THIS BILL THIS
BILL COULD RESULT IN UNKNOWN
BUT POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
LOSS IN LOCAL REVENUE BECAUSE
COUNTIES WOULD NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO COLLECT ANY OUTSTANDING
BALANCES FROM COUNTY AS FAST.
OR COURT ORDER JUVENILE JUSTICE
RELATED FEES IMPOSED BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
INDICATES THAT THIS BILL ILL
RESULT IN A MINIMAL LOSS OF
REVENUE FOR THE JUNE. JUDICIAL
BRANCH DUE TO UNCOLLECTED COURT
ORDER COSTS. ALL RIGHT SEE NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE THAT IS BECAUSE MISTER
AWESOME. YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL- WITH MISS DOLLY VOTING I
AM MR FONG NOT VOTING. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE ARE DONE WITH
MR ALSO WE WILL NOW MOVE TO I
SAW DOCTOR HAN I THINK HE'S OUR
NEXT. GENTLEMEN WALKING IN-
BEFORE WE TAKE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL- I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE AFGHAN AND I'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT AN AMENDMENT.
S. B. THIS IS SB ONE ZERO. TWO
NINE. ONE ZERO TWO NINE SO ON
THE PHONES FIRST OF ALL IF YOU
WANT TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE ZERO
TWO NINE NOW I THE TIME TO
CALL IN YOU SHOULD NOT BE ON
THE PHONES IF YOU'RE HERE FOR
ANY OTHER BILL ONE ZERO TWO
NINE. MISTER PANDA DR PAM I'M
SORRY- THE ASSOCATION OF THE
CHAIR IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO AUTHORIZE THE COUNTY TO FORM
THE HEALTH AUTHORITY FOR
OVERSIGHT PURPOSES ONLY. IN
DATE DELAY THE INFLUENCE OF THE
AUTHORITY UNTIL AFTER THE
UPCOMING R. P. PROCESS WITH
THAT THIS R. P. PROCESS GO
THROUGH- THAT IS AS THE
RECOMMENDATION AS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED OF EMOTION. I HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR ADMITS CREE ON
A SECOND BY DR COURT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROCEED AFTER PM. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HEARING THIS BILL TODAY AND
TURN AWAY PRESENTATION ON ESPYS
TWO SEVENTY FIVE FOUR SIX AND
EIGHT FIFTY TWO. PLEASE TO
PRESENT SB TEN TWENTY NINE
WHICHWOULD AUTHORIZE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SAYS A
DISTRICT BILL TO ESTABLISH A
SPECIAL HEALTH AUTHORITY IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE OUR MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE. SERVICES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WHICH IS A
GEOGRAPHIC MANAGED CARE COUNTY.
THIS BILL HAS NO COST TO THE
STATE IN FACT THE COUNTY ITSELF
WILL USE ITS OWN RESOURCES TO
HELP ESTABLISH AND SUPPORT THIS
HEALTH AUTHORITY. MEDIC OUT
COVERS ABOUT PARTY A THIRD ONE
THREE RESIDENTS IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY LIKE THE REST OF THE
STATE. AND THERE'S BEEN REPORT
AFTER REPORT THAT SHOWS THAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT
DELIVERING THE RESULTS FOR
SACRAMENTO RESIDENTS IN FACT-
THERE IS NO ONE WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE TO BE SURE MEDICARE
IS ACTUALLY WORKING IN
SACRAMENTO UNLIKE PRACTICALLY
EVERY MOST OTHER COUNTIES. BACK
THROUGH THIS BILL. SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SIMPLY SEEKING. PARITY
WAS WHAT. SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WHICH IS THE ONE OTHER COUNTY
WITH GMC ALREADY PASSED AND
WHAT NEARLY EVERY OTHER COUNTY
THAT HAS EVERY COUNTY THAT HAS
A LOCAL INITIATIVE PLANNED A
COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEM
OR SPECIAL THIRTY ALREADY HAS
THAT IS FOR THE PEOPLE LIVE IN
THE COUNTY. WILL BE SERVED BY
MEDIC HOW TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
SAY IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
GRAHAM THAT ACTUALLY SERVING
THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY DURING
COATED. THIS BILL CREATES THIS
COUNTY STAKEHOLDER COMMISSION
HAS HEALTH AUTHORITY TO WEIGH
IN ON WHICH PLANS THE PRIME
HEALTHCARE SERVICES- CONTRACT
WITH WHEN IT ENTERS ITS PLANNED
PROCUREMENT PROCESS. NEXT YEAR.
WITHOUT THIS BILL NOW THERE
WILL BE A COST TO THE HEALTH OF
RESIDENTS IN SACRAMENTO
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE TO COATED. WITHOUT
THIS BILL NOW THERE'S A COST TO
THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AS THE NEEDS OF THE SACRAMENTO
MEDI CAL PROVIDERS CONTINUE TO
BE IGNORED WHICH WE'VE
WITNESSED OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
DECADES. THIS BILL CAME OUT OF
A- STAKEHOLDER PROCESS HAVE
BEEN THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
OVER A YEAR- EVEN BEFORE
BECAUSE OF IT TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THESE DEFICIENCIES. I'M HAPPY
TO ADDRESS THE AMENDMENTS
THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED BY CHAIR
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS-
DURING DISCUSSION ON MY CLOTHES
I DO HAVE AS WITNESSES- DOCTOR
BILL WINSTON WHO REPRESENTS THE
COUNTY IS A DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND SECOND
COUNTY. AND CHECK A FEW IT ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE AT THIS
YEAR HEALTH FOUNDATION HAS ALSO
BEEN HELPING LEAD OUR
STAKEHOLDER- A PROCESS TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I BOWED AND COST
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE AFTER MY
WITNESSES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO THE WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. SO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I'M DOCTOR PETER BEALE
INTENDED SACRAMENTO COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
DIRECTOR. AT CENTER PAN SAID
SACRAMENTO AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES ARE THE ONLY TWO
COUNTY MEANING IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THE GEOGRAPHIC MANAGED
CARE SYSTEM. BUT SAN DIEGO HAS
SIGNIFICANT POWERS OF OVERSIGHT
AND THE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATING IN M. C. OF. THIS
RELEASE SACRAMENTO IS ONE OF
THE ONLY COUNTIES IN THE STATE
IS NOT GET TO HOLD OUR MANAGED
CARE ORGANIZATIONS. OPERATING
IN THE COUNTY ACCOUNTABLE FOR
OUTCOMES THAT FACTION QUALITY.
IF IN TURN HAS LED TO A SYSTEM
WHERE FOUR OUT OF THE FIVE
MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATIONS IN
SACRAMENTO. RANK IN THE BOTTOM
QUARTILE. OF ALL MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATIONS
STATEWIDE IN TERMS OF OUTCOMES.
WE DESERVE BETTER HEALTH CARE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. THE BILL
COMPORT TO SACRAMENTO. DEFAULT
SITE RIGHT. THE WOULD ALLOW IT
TO PROVIDE OVER IS WELL AS THE
BILL TO HAVE A IN WHICH
MEDICARE. INFIELDER SIR R. P.
NOT ONLY THAT TO PUT BY THE
BILL GROUP OF. TECHNICAL BY THE
CENTER PAN BUT THE BILL ITSELF
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH CO
SPONSORS. ASSEMBLY PERSONS
COOPER COOLEY MCCARTY KILEY AND
BETTER DAHLE AND MILTON.
BECAUSE OF THE AMENDMENT THAT
TO THE BILL WE WILL
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO WAIT
CLOSE TO A DECADE TO IMPACT.
WHAT BETTER CAL MASCULINIZATION
BOOKS OR THE COUNTY. ASSEMBLY
DENYING SACRAMENTO AND THEN THE
DAY AND WHO SERVED OVER
200-004-0020 THOUSAND OF OUR
FELLOW CITIZENS.
DISPROPORTIONATELY PEOPLE OF
COLOR. NONETHELESS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. M. ARK
TOLD WITNESS TIME IS TO THAT A
MINUTE AND A HALF SO WE HAVE
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS BUT SINCE
I DID SAY THAT TO BEGIN WITH
WILL. GIVE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
SECOND WITNESS MISTER HEWITT. A
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. I WON'T REPEAT WHAT
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD BUT I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING A
DIVERSE COALITIONS DOCUMENT A
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES. AND REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE MADE OVER
THE PAST YEAR AND COME UP WITH
A SERIES OF RECOMMENDATIONS WE
THINK APPROVING THE DELIVERING.
GREAT HEALTHCARE PERFORMING
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOCUMENTS
IN ORDER ROLE IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. WE ALSO BELIEVE BILL
TO BE PASSED. AS ORIGINALLY
WRITTEN. THE NOT SO WOULD
CONTAIN TO TYPE THE INEVITABLE
RESULTS WE'RE THING OF THE
RESULT. OF THE CULVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WITH ALL GOING SUPPORT
FROM THE- SECURE FILE LOW
INCOME. RESIDENTS YOU CAN USE
THE POWER. ESPECIALLY ON THE-
NAY FROM. BLOOD AND BLACK AND
LYFT NEXT POPULATION. OVER HALF
A COUNTY FROM A BLACK RESIDENTS
PUBLIC BY MEDIC DOWN AND 21% OF
ALL LATINO RESIDENTS ARE
COVERED BY MATH. BELANO
EMPLOYMENT THE TO ARE WE WILL
DENY SACRAMENTO IS REAL. AT
LEAST INTO THE U. S. ONE. YOU
MAY ONLY THE YEAR TWENTY. THE
CHAMPION WITH THE HELP YOU WE
HOPE MEMBERS OF THE THREE WOULD
THAT THIS A TO IS ANTI PRODUCT.
AND ADVANCE THE BILL AT THE
REGIONALLY WE'RE- THAT IS NOT
THE CASE WE WILL TAKE YOU TO
THE WAY FOR PROGRESS. BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT WE DO BETTER
SOONER AND THAT MORE.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
SACRAMENTO USER TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. YOU HAD YOUR TWO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT WE CAN NOW
OPEN UP THE LINES IF THERE ARE
JUST SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE
AND YOUR POSITION. ON SB ONE
ZERO TWO NINE. TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
ALIGN ONE ZERO FOUR ONE OH FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MGBS
HERE ON BEHALF OF S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE SEVENTY ONE ARE YOU
READY. SEVENTY ONE YOU ARE
HAPPENING HERE. HI WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE I'M NOT SURE WHY WE'RE
PUTTING Q. FOR THE BILL WE KNOW
WE ARE NOT TAKING A HOT NIGHT
WE ARE NOT TAKING ANY OTHER
BUILT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
ARE ON THE PHONE AND YOU DO NOT
NEED TO SPEAK ON SB ONE ZERO
TWO NINE YOU SHOULD NOT BE ON
THE PHONE AT THIS POINT. THE
ONLY THE ONLY BILL WE ARE
TAKING SUPPORTER OPPOSITION FOR
IS SB ONE ZERO TWO NINE. THANK
YOU MOVING ALONG WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
PANAMA ON POVERTY IN SUPPORT OF
THAT B. TEN TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING DIANA
DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF F. B. ONE OH TWO NINE.
NOBODY ELSE THANK YOU AT THE
TIME MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU I
SEE NOBODY IN THE GALLERY HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. SCENE NINE WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONES IS THERE
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
TWENTY NINE. SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION ON SB TEN TWENTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MADAM
CHAIR THAK YOU. FINO QUESTION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR UP WE
HAVE NO POSITION ON THIS BILL-
BUT WE DO KNOW POTENTIAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH ADMINISTRATIVE WORK WORK
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO MAKE A
TRANSITION. THANK YOU. WITH
THAT DOCTOR PAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND DIVERSE WELL WHY I DO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAD ABOUT THIS BILL AND
THE AMENDMENT- SACRAMENTO EMC
HAS BEEN HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY FOR SEVERAL DECADES-
WITHOUT INPUT FROM THE ACTUAL
RESIDENTS OF THE COUNTY I AM
VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT- YOU'RE
ASKING FOR AMENDMENT THAT PUTS
THAT OFFER ALMOST ANOTHER
DECADE I THINK THAT- VOICE
NEEDS TO BE HEARD NOW THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD NOW
THE NEXT RETIREMENT. HOWEVER I
ALSO UNDERSTAND AND WILL ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENT IS YOUR PROPERTY-
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO MOVE
IT SURE THAT THE VOICE OF THE
PEOPLE SACRAMENTO WILL
EVENTUALLY BE HEARD. IN THEIR
OWN MEDICAL PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND SO THAT IS- WILL
BE AMENDED COMING OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND WITH THAT IT GETS
OUT ON IN A ROLL CALL THANK YOU
DR PAM. I SAW MISTER MCGUIRE
WALK AND I BELIEVE MISTER
MCGUIRE SB. SIX TWENTY NINE. SO
NOW AGAIN ON THE PHONE YOU
SHOULD ONLY CALL AN IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK ON SB SIX TWENTY NINE
THAT IS THE ONLY BILL THAT YOU
SHOULD BE ON THE PHONE FOR THAT
IS TE ONLY BILL THAT MR
MCGUIRE IS PRESENTING ON. AND
THAT IS THE ONLY BILL WE ARE
TAKING TESTIMONY ON THAT WITH
THAT THIS ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. IT'S MOVE BY
MISS CARILLO AND SECOND BY
DOCTOR PARK YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR IN THE MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE QUAKE SB SIX
TWENTY NINE EXTENDS. CRUCIAL
PROTECTIONS TO MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS AS THE INTERN REPORT ON
EVENTS PROTECTED BY FIRST
AMENDMENT TO SUCH AS MARCHES
AND DEMONSTRATIONS PROTESTS AND
RALLIES. MEANWHILE CALIFORNIA
LAW ALLOWS REPORTERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS TWO
INTERNATIONAL DISASTER
EMERGENCY AREAS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF GATHERING INFORMATION. EVEN
DESPITE A CURFEW THESE
PROTECTIONS DO NOT EXTEND TO
FIRST AND THEN THE PROTEST
MARCHES OR EVENTS IN THIS BILL
WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND THOSE
PROTECTIONS TO THOSE FIRST
AMENDMENT EVENTS. I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO KNOW THAT WE'VE
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
ALONG THE WAY AND THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS NOTES THAT
THE COST OF THIS BILL IS MINOR.
IT WILL ONLY POSE A DESIRABLE
COST TO THE HARD WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN OF CALIFORNIA HAVE A
PATROL AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO UPDATE
POLICIES AND TRAINING
MATERIALS. I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO WILL BE QUICK
AND THAT'S KEVIN BAKER HE'S A
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE
ACLU. MARKING CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER. I WE'LL GO TO. KEVIN
BAKER ON THE LINE. NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES IT'S ALL YOURS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
NUMBERS KEVIN BAKER
CONSOLIDATION OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU MAY KNOW THE ACLU IS
UNDERTAKEN TO REPRESENT A
NUMBER OF REPORTERS HAVE BEEN
THE VICTIMS OF POLICE VIOLENCE
WHILE LAKE IN ATTEMPTING TO
PROVIDE NEWS COVERAGE FOR THE
PUBLIC IN RECENT. MONTHS
CERTAINLY THERE HAVE BEEN NO
CALL TO GO MUCH FURTHER IN OUR
POLICY RESPONSE IN THIS AREA
BUT THIS IS. QUITE A MODEST
MEASURE SB SEVEN TWO SIX TWO
NINE. ASSEMBLY CLARIFIED THAT
AUTHORIZED MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
MAY ENTER AREAS THAT MAY
OTHERWISE BE CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC TO DO A DEMONSTRATION.
AND PROHIBITS OFFICERS FROM
BEING CITED FOR FAILURE TO
DISPERSE OR VIOLATING THE
CURFEW. CONTESTANTS EXISTING
LAW WITH RESPECT TO FRIEDMAN OF
THE PROSECUTORS ARE CLOSED FOR
OTHER REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR- TICKET. THANK YOU
WITH WE OPEN UP THE PHONE. TO
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT ONLY THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THAT THEY
SUPPORT THE BILL. AGAIN IT'S
SIX TO NINE SB SIX TO NINE.
OPERATOR CAN WE OPEN UP A LINE.
SORRY YES ABSOLUTELY PLEASE
WITH YOU TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. NOBODY IS
GOING UP OKAY AB FIVE. I'M
SORRY. AT THE TIME OUR GOAL IS
GOING UP AT THIS TIME THAT'S
PERFECT- I SEE NOBODY AND THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITH THAT IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX TWENTY
NINE. THE SHOW THEIR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. LINE ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE THIRTY TWO
YOU ARE OPEN. ONE ONE THIRTY
TWO ARE YOU MERELY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I HAVE NO RESPONSE.
BEGIN TO SHOW THEIR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MADAM
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME ONE THIRTY TWO RE
QUEUED. BY AGAIN. MEMORY ONE
BRENDA. READ UP ON BEHALF OF
THE LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. WHAT ELSE IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU- WE HAVE
NO POSITION ON THIS BILL- WE
KNOW THAT THE COSTS ON ANY
COSTS ARE LIKELY TO BE MINOR
AND ABSORBABLE FROM THIS BILL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I SEE NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. MISTER MCGUIRE. OF
MANAGERS WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF OF WORK ON THIS
BILL AND SO MANY OTHERS IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE FROM THE COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT CHECK IT OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. WITH S. DOLLY AND MR FONG
NOT VOTING. WITH MR VOEPEL
VOTING NO WITH MISS PETRI
NORRIS VOTING NOW THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT- WE ONLY HAVE I THINK
ONE MORE SENATOR. STE. HIS BILL
MISTER TODD THOUGH SHE COULD
COME TO THE CHAMBERS IN THE
MEANTIME MISTER CALDERON YOU
HAVE A BILL IN FRONT OF US
WOULD YOU LIKE 2% MISTER
CALDERON HAS AB. THREE THREE
THREE ZERO IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. I HAVE. I'M
MOTION BUT DR QUIRK A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO. MISTER CALDERON
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PLEASE PRESENT THIS BILL WHICH
AUTHORIZES FEE INCREASES FOR
VARIOUS BOARDS INTO THE
APARTMENT CONSUMERAFFAIRS IN
THE STATE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM KNOWN AS
CURES A RECENT MEMBERS REDUCE
SCARCITY INCREASES TO TWELVE
DOLLARS FOR TWO YEARS STARTING
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
NINE DOLLARS BEGINNING APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO ALIGN
WITH THE CURRENT. FEE SCHEDULE
IF REVENUES EXCEED REASONABLE
REGULATORY COSTS THIS BILL
AUTHORIZED AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO REDUCE THE FEE TO THE
REASONABLE REGULATORY COST- IT
ALSO AUTHORIZES THE INCREASES
FOR THE BOARDS OF ACUPUNCTURE
BEHAVIOR SCIENCES PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICINE TO ADDRESS BUDGET
SHORTFALLS UNDERSTANDING THE
TIMES HERE IN THE HOUSTON
CREASES ARE BEING ARE BEING
PROPOSED TO PREVENT THESE
PROGRAMS FROM BEING INSOLVENT
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
CREATING SIGNIFICANT LICENSING%
BACKLOG OF THAT RESPECT WE ARE
FROM THE VOTING WITH ME ON THE
PHONE. IN SUPPORT IS A DCA
DIRECTOR KIM KURT MEYER AND
CHRIS RYAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE ALL RIGHT WE WILL- THE
COMBINED WITNESSES HAVE TWO
MINUTES ON THE PHONE. WE CAN GO
TO THE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
NOW. WEIGHTED DOWN ONE UP FOR
LINES PRESS ZERO YOU'RE SO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE DO A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP. FIRED I CAN AT AND
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ANYBODY MAY
HAVE REGARDING THIS BILL THANK
YOU. AND IT IS COULD TRY
INTERNAL PARTNER JEFF IS ALSO
AVAILABLE FOR A TECHNICAL
QUESTION THANK YOU. THIS IS AB
THREE THREE THREE ZERO ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES.
WE DO WE WILL LIE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS KATHLEEN COOPER AND I'M
BEHALF AT THE PODIUM TRICK
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA ARE
EXECUTIVE BRIAN NAY FLINT AND
OUR BOARD MEMBERS WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THE
WORK THEY PUT IN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LOL LINE ONE SEC-
SKEWS ME FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD FIVE SEVEN. THE MORNING
MANTER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BENJAMIN
BUT YEAH I AM THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD AND THE BOARD
WHAT THE FASHION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME GREAT WELL NOW THAT
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION F AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY. NOBODYIN THE GALLERY
WE CAN SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION. TO
SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
THIS BILL. MADAM CHAIR THERE'S
NOBODY QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING HI AMY JARVIS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE THESE P.
INCREASES ARE NECESSARY TO
MAINTAIN EACH FUND'S SOLVENCY
AND CONTINUE LICENSING
ENFORCEMENT REQUIREMENTS
WITHOUT COMPROMISING CONSUMER
PROTECTION REDUCING SERVICES
LICENSEES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I KNOW QUESTIONS YOU MAY CLOSE
MISTER CALDERON. SPOKE WHEELS
WHEN I VOTE AND I GET OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL WITH MISS EGGMAN
NOT VOTING TO MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS VOTING NOW THANK
YOU. OUR LAST PRESENTATION
WOULD BE BY SENATOR ALTHOUGH.
THEY'RE CALLING HER. I KNOW SHE
WAS THE LADY. SHE'S NOT A
BUILDING ALL RIGHT- WE CAN
EITHER MOVE MISTER TADO TO
THURSDAY AND TAKE IT BEFORE WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS WILL
HAVE TO TAKE OR SOMEBODY IF
THEY ARE SO WILLING TO PRESENT
ON BEHALF OF MISTER TYLER THANK
YOU MISS EGGMAN. DOCTOR EGGMAN.
ON BEHALF OF MR TADO SB NINE
SEVENTY FOUR IT'S A DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TEXT AN EXEMPTION TO
STATE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS
SERVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ITEM. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION BY. THIS CREDO IN
A SECOND BY DR PORT- WE CAN
TAKE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE.
LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES BUT OR
WE CAN JUST GO TO SUPPORT.
SHARE ON OFFENDERS- TITLES
WITNESSES ARE THE ONLY ONE THAT
THIS MORNING. I MEGA. ALL RIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY
RIGHT SB NINE SEVENTY FOUR.
CORRECT GOOD MORNING AT MANAGER
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER AND
I'M A SENIOR COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT SPECIALIST AT THE
HOPE CENTER PRICES AT THE
APPOINTMENT AFTER AT THE
NINETEEN FOUR ALONG WITH OUR
FELLOW PUT BONTA RURAL
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION WE ARE THE TWO
LARGE ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
STATE WORKING ALONGSIDE OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. TO SECURE
SAFE DRINKING WATER. EDUCATED
YOU. SB INE SEVEN WASN'T BY
THE OF. LIKE THE LEMON COVE OUT.
COMMUNITIES OUT OF WORK FOR
MANY YEARS FIRST WATER. A
STRUGGLE THAT IS ONGOING AND
COMMUNITIES AND MANY MORE TOO
MANY MORE ACROSS THE STATE. BY
CREATING A NEAR THE GREAT
TENSION PRETTY CALLING IT VITAL
DRINKING WATER PROJECT AT THE
NINETEEN FOR WILL ENSURE THAT
PROJECTS ARE PLANNED AND
CONSTRUCTED MARKET LAND
QUICKLY. GIVING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF. DOLLARS IN
PLANNING POP ALONG THE WAY PER
ELIGIBLE PROJECT STRETCHING
EXISTING AND FUTURE
APPROPRIATIONS FURTHER ENSURING
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS FINALLY
AT STATE DRINKING WATER. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME RESPECTFULLY.
OUTSIDE THE- THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY THE PHONE STRESS
TO READ TO THEIR- AND- FOR SB.
NINE SEVENTY FOUR. SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AND LIKE SIXTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE DAILY
GATHERED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT. SIX POINT NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
AGAIN NOT ENSURING MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE
SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS EXTREMELY GRATEFUL
FOR THE AMENDMENT IT'S YOUR
STAFF THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
MEDICARE. THANK YOU I SEE NONE
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY IS
THERE ANYBODY ON THE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE SB NINE
SEVENTY FOUR. CHAU OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP
THANK YOU. NOBODY HAS QUEUED UP
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU WILL GO
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MADAM- WE HAVE NO POSITION
ON THIS BILL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE INDICATES
THAT THE BILL WILL ELIMINATE
WORKLOAD COST. AND FEE REVENUE
FOR SEE FULL REVIEW ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PROJECTS THAT QUALIFY
FOR THIS EXEMPTION. ALL RIGHT.
THAT IS. THE TOTAL TESTIMONY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IRA
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
TADO. CHECK IT OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU. A MIND READER
TODAY ALL RIGHT- WITH THAT WE
WILL AT LEAST THE BILL'S PLEASE
THAT ARE GOING ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MADAM SECRETARY. ALLEN
THIRTEEN EIGHTY. ARCHULETA NINE
OH SEVEN WITH THE MINUTES. FIVE
SEVENTY THREE AND SIX FIFTY
THREE GLAZIER TWELVE THIRTY TWO
WITH THE MINUTES HERTZBERG FIVE
TWENTY TWO JOHN EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT MCGUIRE SIXTY SEVEN RUBIO.
ELEVEN FORTY ONE WIENER NINE
THIRTY TO AT THE MOMENT
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE
WITH THE MAMMOTHS COMMUNITY
CHURCH TWELVE FIFTY FIVE.
CAMINO HUMAN SERVICES TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO YEAH COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION TWELVE NINETY
ONE. WE HAVE A MOTION ON
CONSENT BY DR CORPUS SECOND BY
MR BIGELOW AND THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL THANK YOU- FOR
WORKING TOGETHER TO GET
SOMEBODY BILLS ON CONSENT. AT
OUR SECOND READING WILL BE
THOSE BILLS THAT ARE MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ
THOSE BILLS. ALLEN SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN. TEN FORTY FOUR ARCHULETA
EIGHT NINETY FIVE ATKINS NINE
NINETY FIVE ELEVEN TWENTY
BRADFORD TWO OR THREE CABALLERO
FOURTEEN TEN FOURTEEN FIFTY
NINE DOLLY NINE TWENTY ONE
NINETY NINE DOT. 214-884-1230
SEVEN DIROCCO. NINE ELEVEN
ELEVEN THIRTEEN NINETY NINE
GALGIANI SIX TWENTY SEVEN
HERTZBERG THREE SIXTY NINE.
HILL. 793-865-1150 NINE HUESO
THIRTEEN OH ONE. FOR TARO.
ELEVEN TEN TWELVE. JACKSON
TWELVE SEVEN THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE REQUIRED FOR THIRTY ONE
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE MINING NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PAN. TWO SEVENTY
FIVE FOUR OH SIX EIGHT FIFTY
TWO PORTANTINO SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT TWELVE NINETY NINE. RUBIO.
TWO NINETY TWO SIX FOURTEEN
SKINNER. THIRTY THREE SEVEN
SEVEN SIX TWO SIXTY FOUR STERN.
SEVEN THIRTY NINE THIRTEEN
TWENTY THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT A
NUMBER. SIX SIXTY FIVE NINE
EIGHTY ELEVEN NINETY SIX MY
COFFEE NINE AWAIT. WIENER. FIVE
NINETY TWO EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
NINE OH TWO WILK FOUR OH NINE
FIVE EIGHTY COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU THOSE
BILLS HAVE BEEN MOVED TO THIS
FILE WITH A BILLS ON THIS IS I
WILL JUST OF ON THURSDAY AT
THIS TIME IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER YOUR OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT FOR ANY OF THOSE BILLS
THAT HAVE BEEN MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WHERE THE AUTHOR
HAS WAY PRESENTATION. NOW IS
THE TIME TO CALL IN- AND SIMPLY
STATE YOUR NAME THE BILL AND
YOUR POSITION THAT IF ALL WE'RE
DOING ON BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE WILL
NOT HAVE A FULL HEARING. WILL
START HERE IN THE GALLERY YOU
MAY PROCEED. A MANAGER MEMBERS
ALEX CHORES WITH STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF- UP
FOR GROWTH ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE NINE
NINE FIVE ATKINS S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY ATKINS ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE
WINNER. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF COMP TIA
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FOUR
ZERO SIX BY DR PAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL IN THE GALLERY I SEE
ONE MORE PERSON. CARE CENTERS-
NAME IS FANCY KAHLER IN THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS CHAIR PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSED
INVESTIGATORS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
SB NINE OH EIGHT UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED. WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
FEDERAL LAW AS WELL THAT'S JUST
YOUR YOUR POSITION IS ALL WE'RE
TAKING TODAY WILL POSE WITH
AMANDA THANK YOU THANK YOU. SEE
NOTE. THE PHONES THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT HAS CALLED
AND IT WANTS TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ANY OF
THE BILLS THAT WERE PLACED ON
SUSPENSE. M. PLEASE PRESS STAR
FOLLOWED BY THE WHAT THE SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE GET. I SOMEHOW GOTTEN
THE SUPPORT LINE BUT- MY NAME'S
CHRISTOPHER LEGRAND REPRESENT
KEEP LA MOVING UP FROM SANTA
MONICA AND I OPPOSE STRENUOUSLY
SB NINE OH TWO SB ELEVEN TWENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WILL
ALIGN FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JAMES OF OUR JUNIOR
BEHALF OF MINORITY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN PATROLMAN
CONVENIENCE STORE WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS MENTAL THE MINUTE
OUT ON IT SEVEN NINE THREE
HEALTH THANK YOU. WHY ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
DYER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE HAVE VISIONS ON
NUMBERS DON'T THINK MANY BY
MANAGEMENT EMPATHIZE OUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE FIVE
HUNDRED JACK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WATER LINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN EIGHTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. WILL BE ONE WILL
GO TO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIX BUSH. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HARVEY
ROSENFIELD THE CONSUMER
WATCHDOG ON THE OCTOBER
OPPOSITION ONE OH THREE WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THAT. NINETY
TEN THANK YOU. WHY ONE OH FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
STACY TRAVIS I URGE YOU
STRONGLY TO OPPOSE BILLS ELEVEN
TWENTY AND NINE OH TWO DON'T
DECIMATE OUR STATE THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN I GEHRY FROM
LEGAL AID AT WORK THANK YOU
TRUMP FOR PRESS EIGHT THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY YOU ARE OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS PAMELA GIVE BERMAN I'M
A MEMBER OF THE PANORAMA CITY
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL AND I WANT
TO- DO VERY STRONGLY TO OPPOSE
SENATE BILL. ELEVEN TWENTY NINE
ZERO TWO EIGHT NINE NINE FIVE
THEY ARE COMMUNITY KILLERS
THANK YOU. BY ONE TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING OF THE AFFABLE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
FIVE. AND INTRAPARTUM SB SIX
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOU. ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO DAVID FLORIDA YES
WE CAN TALK ABOUT ON BEHALF OF
THE L. SB ELEVEN TWENTY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. ONE TWO ZERO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY TWO OH
FIVE PLEASE ON MUTE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ENGAGE YES ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
FIVE SENATOR JACKSON. ONE FIFTY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. I REMEMBER
OKAY COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE NINE FIVE
ELEVEN TWENTY AND NINE OH TWO
AND IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
NINETY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MOVING ALONG WILL GO TO-
WINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JAMIE
MORGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORED SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE I LOVE TO LIKE TO
VOICE THE FROM THE PORT THE
OTHER CHARACTERS. CAMPAIGN
CONTRACT THE THREE. AMERICA
CANCER SOCIETY CANCER ACTION
NETWORK WE CAN I THINK UP
INTERACTION. YEAH I'M INTENT
TRANSACTION IN THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. GOING MOVING ALONG
TO THE LINE. EIGHTY ADAM HARPER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO S. B. O. FOUR OH
NINE AND THE CRIMINALIZATION OF
THE RECEIPT OF SAND GRAVEL AND
CONCRETE BY LEGITIMATE BUSINESS
WITH ENTITIES. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS CAROL
DALY COUNTY BUSINESS-
FEDERATION WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
NINE OO TO TWELVE NINETY NINE
AND FOURTEEN TEN WE OPPOSE
STRONGLY THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AND WE'LL GO. TO ONE FIFTY.
WELL I DON'T WANT. OKAY JERRY.
WE ARE YOU PLEASECALL AT ALL
SORRY HELLO I'M CALLING- ON THE
FLOOR AND HEALTH ACTIVE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA BEEN ON
PROBATION THANK YOU. WHY NOT
ONE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
LAURIE BRUNNER BEHALF PARENTS
BABY NEEDS TO GROW PAY. PART OF
A CO OF AND FIFTY SEVEN OREGON
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
AUTHORED BY KILL WITH NO
EXEMPTIONS. WHY SIXTIES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LIKE SIXTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. SO WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETY NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE NINETY ONE. OUR
LAURIE BRUNNER WITH PENSIONS
MAKING IS THAT CORRECT. AS
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE AS PART OF A
COALITION OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN ORGANIZATIONS WITH
NO EXCEPTIONS. THANK YOU LINE
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THAT SENATE
BILL ONE FORTY ONE RUBIO THANK
YOU. ONE ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR A NUMBER
OF EVENTS CALLING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE OH TWO BY
SENATOR WIENER AND I THINK
ELEVEN TWENTY BY SENATOR ATKINS
ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA B. AND A THREE PIECE
COLLECTION WHICH INCLUDES TMT
PARTNER THE TEMPLATE OF
CONFIRMATION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION I
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR NAY AROUND PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA. ON SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR JACKSON
ACTUALLY TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN BY.
SENATOR GOT THANK YOU. FIVE SIX
PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS WHERE THEY GO OVER NON GAAP
OF FIVE AND WE ARE IN OF A
THIRTY THREE RIGHT NOW SKINNER
THANK YOU. NINE TO TEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS A CHIP TED
GAIL- THE PRESENTING MICHAEL
COLEMAN CONVENIENCE STORES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TO
TWENTY YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
DELUCA IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE FROM THE FOLLOWING
CITIES DON PABLO HELLO WHILE TO
BERKELEY SAN LEANDRO OAKLAND
AND CONCORD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TWO TWO NINE ARE
YOU MUTED. GOOD MORNING MA'AM
HAVE ADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS KATHY DID
TELL OF WITH METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY
FOUR. BY SENATOR ALAN. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT. ANNEX WE WILL
GO TO. WHY AM ONE THIRTY
BETWEEN ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. POLITECNICA
CALIFORNIA YOU'RE SO RIGHT
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT X. P.
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN DODD TO
INCREASE ACCESS CAN DECREASE
OVERALL COSTS THE MATERNITY
CARE IN CALIFORNIA. MY. TO
TWENTY ONE. ONE MOMENT.
ACTUALLY I USE A WALKER LINE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'VE BEEN AND GREEN FIND
THE FORTY THREE YEAR RESIDENTS
OF SANTA MONICA AND A BOARD
MEMBER OF OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
GOING MONTH BY AND- TO BILLS
ELEVEN TWENTY NINE OH TWO. AND
FOR. THOSE. NINETY NINE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WHY
NINE FIVE GO AHEAD. ASK WHICH
CITIZENS PRESERVING MENACE WE
URGE A NO VOTE ON SB ELEVEN
TWENTY AND SB NINE OH TWO
ENDING YET SO ON. TWELVE NINETY
NINE APICAL OF THEM THANK YOU.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JOHNNY NASH THE FORTY FOUR
YEAR STAKEHOLDER HERE IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES ACTOR JOHN LEOPOLD
SB ONE ONE TWO ZERO AND NINE
ZERO TWO THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT JUGGLING ACT ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL HODIERNA SET
UP IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN
NINETY THREE. ONE ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. THIS IS
KATIE WATER WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
WORK AND FAMILY COALITION WE'RE
IN SHOCK BEFORE. THE SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
THANK YOU. YOUR LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ADNAN ROD
SECRETARY OF REST OF THE S.
SUNSET CLAYTON AND COMMONWEALTH
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS TOGETHER
IN LOS ANGELES WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN TWENTY AND SB
NINE AND TWO THANK YOU. WHY
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S MELISSA
MCCAFFREY ON BEHALF OF THE
AIRCRAFT OWNERS AND PILOTS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND THEN AVIATORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY INTRODUCED BY
SENATOR ACHEN AND SENATE BILL
MINDER TO INTERVIEWED BY CENTER
WHEN THEY'RE- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR OPEN.
MOVING ALONG ONE TWENTY NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD WHAT. HI
MY NAME IS MARKETS AVERY AND
I'M CALLING FROM THE LIMBERG
PARK APRIL THIRTY SOUTH LOS
ANGELES I'M A HOMEOWNER HERE
AND I BAKER RIPLEY PULLS SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY AND NINE OH
TO ENACT THE PORT. ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT UNTIL. TWELVE OO NINE
THANK YOU. WINE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I. EIGHTY FIVE. WELL
LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS HOLLY
OFF MORNE I AM A RESIDENT OF
NORTH REDONDO BEACH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB ELEVEN
TWENTY AND OPPOSE NINE ZERO TWO
SB NINETY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LIKE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ROBERT I BELIEVE THE
LIBERATING HANDCOCK HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE GROUP I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE
NINETY FIVE. ELEVEN TWENTY AND
NINE OH TWO AND WE SUPPORT
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY NINE.
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SANDY HUBBARD AND WHAT'S
AVAILABILITY HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION WE CANNOT THEIR
NEIGHBORS IN SHERMAN OAKS TO
OPPOSE. THREE NINE OH TWO NINE
NINE FIVE ELEVEN TWENTY AND
SUPPORT TWELVE NINETY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
TREVOR MILLER OPTED FOR MEMBER
OF THE LADERA HEIGHTS CIVIC
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SB NINE
DON'T SHOOT. THANK YOU LINE.
SKEWS ME LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AT. YES MY NAME IS DIANE
THOMAS I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
CARSON L. A. COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. SB. ONE ONE
TWO ZERO THANK YOU. BY ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE CALL. PRESIDENT
SUPPORTED AT. 840-675-8790.
THREE NINE EIGHT EIGHT TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. BY ONE
SEVENTY COMMUTERS. I YES ARE
THERE A COUPLE ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB. 406-758-7939 EIGHTY AND
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I ONE FORTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. I WON FOUR ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR AVAILABLE OF SAN
ANGELO. AND I AM BE A LITTLE
TWENTY ATKINS SB NINE HOME TO
WHERE THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MARY MCFADDEN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M SPEAKING FOR
MY FAMILY WHICH IS OF HEALTH
FORTY PEOPLE AND FOR SEVERAL
FRIENDS AND IT'S SMALL PROPERTY
OWNER AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
NINE OH TWO SB NINE NINETY FIVE
AND LOCUSTS SPECIALLY SB ELEVEN
TWENTY AS AN ENTRENCHES
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY EVEN
FURTHER THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU OVERALL I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I'M I'VE WE'VE WE'VE
LET SOME OF THESE COMMENTS GO
BY BUT WE JUST NEED PEOPLE TO
STATE THEIR POSITION ON THE
BILL AND NO ANCILLARY
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE BILL THANK
YOU. TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
ENGAGE IN FRANKLIN COURT OF
COALITION WHAT. YOU POST ELEVEN
TWENTY NINE OH TWO EIGHT THE
COURT TWELVE NINETY NINE THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WILL ALIGN ONE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS RECALL WITH LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA AND THE CULTURAL
ACTION NETWORK WE OPPOSE S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY OPPOSE SB NINE OH
TO OPPOSE S. B. NINE NINE FIVE.
AND SUPPORT S. B. TWELVE NINE
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE.
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MAILINGS
GAS AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF AND MY NEIGHBORS IN
SUNNYDALE WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
ONE ONE TWO ZERO AND S. B. NINE
ZERO TWO THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SIXTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING- THIS IS CHRIS FOR SAKE
FROM THE WEST FOR MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
AND WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ONE THREE EIGHT THREE AND SB
ONE FOUR ONE ZERO THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS THE KEY TO THE
PRESENT THING TENS OF EVERY
CHAPTER O THE AMERICAN
PETROLEUM AND UNIONS OR
ASSOCIATIONS AND ATTENTIVE AND
DEMOCRATS AND OWNERS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY OPPOSING.
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU MOVING ALONG PHOTO LINE TO
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES JODY
JOHN GEORGIA. SOUTH LOS
ANGELES- I STRONGLY OPPOSE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AT ELEVEN
TWENTY AND NINE OH TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OVER LINE ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IT BUT NO
REFUND AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
WHY TO FORTY TWO. OUR CAFE ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND AT THE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR JACKSON THANK YOU THANK
YOU I TO SIXTY THREE. STANDING
UP FOR WHAT THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS
POPULOUS NANI CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION SB SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- TWO FIFTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPENING. HI MY NAME IS
JEAN ARIELLE I'M A NURSE
MIDWIFE IN YOLO COUNTY AND I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THANK YOU.
TWO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN IN SCOPE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORTER SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE AND F. B. TWO SEVEN FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WON
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. YOU ARE OPEN. THIS IS
JILL STEWART I'M THINKING FOR
ANGELENOS RETREATED TO THE
COUNTY WIDE ORGANIZATION AND
THE GLOBAL CALIFORNIA A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION WE ARE
VERY MUCH ALIGNED WITH TENANTS
TOGETHER IN OPPOSING SB ELEVEN
TWENTY AND SB NINE OH TWO AND
WE ARE FOR PORTANTINO'S SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE WHICH HELPED
IT IS INSTEAD OF PUNISHING THEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE TO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD CHIU
FORTY LET ME- I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY
NEIGHBORS I AM A RESIDENT OF
LAFAYETTE AND I AM A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME OWNER AS WELL AS A
MULTI FAMILY OWNER OF THE
PROPERTY WITH FOUR UNITS
SENATE. AND I STRONGLY AND MY
OTHER PEOPLE IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSE NINE NINE
FIVE WE OPPOSE ONE ONE TWO ZERO
AND WE. OPPOSE NINE ZERO TWO
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FIVE NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. WELL I TWO FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES DANIEL
CANDOR CARTER WITH CORBIN
KAISER AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
CLIENTS- THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE. ELEVEN NINETY SIX AND SB
NINE ZERO EIGHT. AND ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE WE EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE EIGHT ZERO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MOVING
ALONG A LINE ONE IS BEING I TO
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS AMBER. AMOSKEAG
NURSE MIDWIVES IN SUNYVALE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU. YEAH WE WILL GO TO.
LINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF YOU CAN COUNT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF IT AND
HEALTH THAT WE FORGOT TO
MENTION ALSO SUPPORT- SB TWELVE
NINETY NINE THANK YOU. WHY TO
SIXTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. I'M A
LOT OF COMPLAINTS WILL BE
COALITION FOR TOBACCO AND
VOEPEL- IN SUPPORT SB SEVEN
NINETY. THANK YOU. AND LINE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR
CONYERS LAWYER REAL ESTATE
BROKER HOMEOWNERS LOS PRINTED
IN A THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED WHOLE
H. AWAY CALLING INCREASED DRAW
ONLY OPPOSE A LEADING TWENTY
NINE OH Q. AND NINE NINE FIVE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ONE TWO NINE
NINE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN. YES
REPEAT I OPPOSE S. B. ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN. ONE EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT DAVID YEAH
THIS IS DAVID WEEKLY
STAKEHOLDER AND SILVER LAKE
AREA AND POLITICAL LAKE AREA OF
LOS ANGELES OPPOSING ELEVEN
TWENTY POSING NINE OUT TO
SUPPORTING ONE TWENTY NINE AND
ASKING FOR A FUTURE OPPORTUNITY
TO ELABORATE OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
COURTNEY TOWARD. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SEVEN NINE THIRTY. WELL
I AM ONE THAT YOU ARE ALL.
THIRTY ONE. IN ONE NINETY SEVEN.
BARBARA GRADY HELLO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF WHAT'S WITHOUT
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHICH TO VOICE
OUR STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB.
NINE OH TWO ELEVEN TWENTY NINE
NINETY FIVE AS WELL AS OUR
SUPPORT. TWO FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHAT. MORNING LEILANI
WHEN THEY WERE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE AT. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
THE NINETY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO HELLO. YEAH ONE NINETY
ONE YOUR OPEN UP HI HEY- I'M
CALLING FOR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
FOR ACCESS TO MIDWIFERY- FOR
PRESIDENT AND ALSO CONSUMER AYE
OPPOSED SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIRTY NINE
THREE ZERO. YEAH EMILY GIVE
BERMAN FROM THE PANORAMA CITY
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL I FORGOT
TO TAKE MY VERY STRONG SUPPORT
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY NINE
THAT THE RIGHT WAY TO HANDLE
INCREASING HALEY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WILL ALIGN TO OUR
SKEWS ME ONE MOMENT. WELL ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
THREE ZERO. THIRTY YOU ARE OPEN.
ARE MOVING ON TO NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MANY
CLEARLY CARRY OUT AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR RESIDENTS IN EL SERENO
COORDINATING COMMITTEE MEMBER
OF UNITED CALTRAIN TENANTS
ASSOCIATION CALLING TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE- SB NINE WHICH IS
DISCRIMINATORY AND NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THANK YOU THANK YOU
PLEASE CALL IF YOU CAN JUST
STICK TO YOUR NAME AND THE BILL
IN YOUR POSITION THANK YOU.
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS PATRICK CALDWELL.
AND HUMOR IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE. OPPOSED SB
ONE TWO THREE SEVEN THANK YOU.
THE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO TWENTY THREE ARE
OPEN. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ROBERT WRIGHT CALLING FROM
AVOCADO HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LIFE AND PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS. WE ARE- OPPOSING
IT HAD TO BE NINE ZERO EIGHT ON
THE COMMENDED. TWO SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YOUR OPEN. HELLO. YES GO AHEAD
I MEAN YES. JOHN CAMPBELL ON
THE MIDWIFERY QUIEN VIDEO OR
THE BACKPACK AND PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE LIBERTY I WOULD STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
DOLLARS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JACKIE ECKLER I AM A
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
TORRANCE. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. SB. NINE ZERO TWO ONE
ONE TWO ZERO AND I SUPPORT- ONE
TWO NINE NINE. SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. HELLO IF THIS IS
MICHAEL STEINER AT THE WESTWOOD
HIGHLANDS NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION AND SAN FRANCISCO
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE
BILLS. ONE ONE TWO ZERO NINE
ZERO TWO. AND IT NINE NINE FIVE
AND WE SUPPORT SENATE BILL ONE
TWO NINE NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY POWER BILLION FOR
MIGHTY PAPERS LLC- WE ARE IN
TRONG OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
NINE THREE THANK YOU. TWO SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS JODY CAN TURN AROUND
AND GO BACK ON MY BACK LIKE I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE OPEN
BETTER BURKE FOUNDATION THE
DEVELOPER AND AUTHOR PETER AND
OPERATING PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WE STRUGGLING TO COPE SB. ONE
THREE THREE SEVEN BY CANADA DOT.
THANK YOU TO SERVE FIVE PLEASE
CALL. MATT ROBINSON KIND OF
PERMANENT STATUS THE COURT OF
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE LINE TWO
EIGHT ZERO YOU ARE OPEN. THIS
IS BOB NAYLOR REPRESENTING
FIELDS TED IN COMPANY AND
ORANGE COUNTY PRO HOUSING
BUSINESS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB NINE OH TWO S. B.
ELEVEN TWO OF AN S. B. NINE
NINE FIVE. TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT WE WANT TO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH MY NAME IS ROBERTO FLORES-
ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
CONTRACT IN. THE OFFICE DURING
A COMMUNITYLAND TRUST AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
FAMILY DISPLACEMENT WE ARE IN A
BOMB OPPOSITION OF IT BEING
NINE. WHY TO TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANGELO FLORES I'M PART OF THE
UNITED CALTRANS TENANTS AND-
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE THAT
WAS THE PLACE WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES. TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS GERRY
GEBEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
LOS FORGIVENESS MALIBU COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS CALLING TO
OPPOSE S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY.
THANK YOU LINE TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT EXCUSE ME TWO SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ATTY
FRANCO ON THE APLICAR POIGNANT
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT AT THE FIFTY
SEVEN AND SB SIX TO SEVEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH. TWO EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS SUMMER
HERE FIX THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE BOARD WITH THE- AND WEAPONS
TO SB ONE TWO THREE. BECAUSE OF
IF MINUTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DON'T WANT TO EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI TINA
LOUISE JOY AND BIRTHING
FOUNDATION I'M CALLING FOR
OPPOSE S. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
WERE TO SKEWS ME TO EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BILLY WALL FROM A
LICENSED PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR
HEAR CALIFORNIANS VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS- CONSTITUENT OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- MEGHAN DAHLE
ARE YOU TO VOTE NO ON SB NINE
OH EIGHT MáS IS AMENDED TO
ENSURE A LICENSED PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO OBTAIN A SECOND LICENSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. CRYPTIC
CORLEY I'M WITH CONNECTS THE
NINE CAMPAIGN I AM OPPOSED TO
BILL SB NINE NINE FIVE SB ONE
ONE TWO ZERO SB NINE OH TWO
THANK YOU. LYING TO THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING ON WE
WILL GO TO LINE. THREE
NINETEEN. YES THIS IS CHRIS
REYNOLDS AND I AM A PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR IN THE CONSTITUENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. I'M
WORRIED ABOUT NOW ONE SB NINE
AWAIT I LOVE HIS AMENDED OUT
ONE MAKE SURE FIVE
INVESTIGATORS THANK YOU THANK
YOUNG LIFE THANK YOU PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL. LINE THREE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KEVIN DE KEPT KALRA AND BECAUSE
OF THE AMERICAN PETROLEUM
CONVENIENCE STORES LOCATION
SACRAMENTO REPRESENTING OVER
THREE HUNDRED FIFTH NOTHING
I'LL DEFINITELY OPPOSED SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. ONE TWO
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MAGGIE MCLAUGHLIN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY
NEIGHBORS IN THE SEVEN TEN
CORRIDOR HELLO TO SB NINE THANK
YOU. ONE THREE ZERO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WARNING THIS IS A
SHAUN DIDDY A LICENSED PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR CONSTITUENT OF-
ASSEMBLY A PERSON NOT DOLLARS-
I AM OBJECTING TO SB NINE OH
EIGHT UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU
CAN CAMP VYING TO NINETY SEVEN
EUROPE AND. I AM. TO NINETY
SEVEN. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE.
ONE ONE THREE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO MY NAME
IS KATHLEEN BELL- I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION AND
A PRACTICING MIDWIFE A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR PLEASE REPORT SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU THREE TWENTY SIX WHO
ARE OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS NOW
OUR DRAFT ON A PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR AND I'M CALLING AS
A CONSTITUENT OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RICHARD BLOOM. URGING VOTE NO
ON SB NINE OH EIGHT UNLESS IT
IS AMENDED TO ENSURE THAT
LICENSED PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A
SECOND LICENSE PLEASE A MAN
THANK YOU SB NINE AWAIT. AND WE
DO HAVE A ON ONE OR TWO WE DO
HAVE TWO MORE ONE MOMENT THE
OPERATORS ARE GATHERING MILLS.
AND WE WERE LIKE THREE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
THAT. THE MOMENT THE ONE THREE
THIRTY GO AHEAD I THINK WE CAN
YES THIS IS A VERY LARGE THE
NEXT TO NINE AND WE OPPOSE
SENATE BILL NINE OH TWO NINE
NINE FIVE AND ONE ONE TWO.
THANK YOU. BY ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WHAT
TWENTY FIVE OR THIRTY NINE YEAR
OPEN I. WON FIFTY NINE. WELL I
WILL GO TO LINE. TWO THIRTY ONE
THESE. HELLO THAT WOULD BE YES
YOU'RE OPEN OKAY MY NAME IS
MIKE SAID AIDID GADAMER
COMPONENT TO STRONGLY. SB
ELEVEN. NINE AUG TWO NINE FIVE
THANK YOU. EACH KIND OF. THANK
TWO THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THE SYSTEM I WOULD TO TURN
WITH CAL TENANTS I STRENUOUSLY
TO PROCEED AND CONTENT OF
DROWNED AFFECTS BE NINE THANK
YOU. THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS PAUL
HANSBERRY I SHOULD TO S. B. C.
TO. WITH CLARIFICATIONS
RESEARCH FUNDING. THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AM
BLACKWOOD ON BEHALF OF ANCESTRY
AND TWENTY THREE ME IN FAVOR OF
SB NINE EIGHTY BURKE THANK YOU.
ONE TO NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWO NINETY NINE YEAR
OPEN. OKAY MOVING ALONG WE WILL.
THREE TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD
TWENTY. THREE TWENTY TWO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK. HREE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN THREE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE THIRTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIE KEPT
TIME APPROPRIATIONS CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY SENATE BILL. NINE OH TWO
SENATE BILL NINE NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU THREE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BEFORE
YOU ARE OPEN. THREE FORTY CAN
YOU HEAR. HELLO. YES OFFICER.
THREE FORTY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK. YEAH I'M A WHOLE SENATE
BILL. SEVEN NINE THREE. TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. OKAY
THIRTY BILLION OF YOU ON THE
LINE IT HAD BEEN THE WAY THEY
WILL GET IT THE NEW. BETTER IT
WOULD BE ALRIGHT WE HAVE SO
MANY PARTICIPANTS THAT HAVE
DROPPED WOULD JUST LIKE TO RE.
THE QUEUE I'LL READ EVERYBODY.
OKAY WHEN MOMENT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. SPECIALIST TAKE
A SECOND. THE CAN OF. OKAY
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
I TO SHOW YOUR STANCE ON THESE
pBY ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU
HAVE NOT DONE SO ALREADY. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE DON CARE ON
BEHALF OF THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE OPPOSED TO SB
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED. WHY ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
EVAN STRAND I'M A LONG TERM
TENANT IN PASADENA. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AT B. NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO NINETY FIVE YOU'RE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JEREMY
ERICKSON AND ICE OPPOSE IT AT.
SEVEN NINE THREE. TWO TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS RUBEN- I'M OPPOSED TO SB.
NINE TWO SEVENTY YEAR OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
GLADWIN I AM IN SUPPORT OF BILL
NUMBER SB. ONE TWO THREE SEVEN.
TUESDAY I GIVE ME THREE. WE GET
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND TWO
SEVENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN.
SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE YES. HI JOHN CAMPBELL IN
THE COUPON REQUIRED GET ME OUT
OF THE BOX PRESIDENT A
QUALIFIED TO BE A BAD OF THE
REPRESENTING OF AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AT. THREE ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN STOP. THANK YOU NEXUS
LIGHT FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
LAURA CALLING I'M STRONG. SB
ONE TWO THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO A FIVE YOU ARE ALL. HI
GOOD THE PMR PAY WITH SMALL
BUSINESSMEN CALLING IN STRONG
AT THE THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU
THREE COULD EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS EMILY
I'M THE THIRD OF NURSE MIDWIFE
AND UNTIL AND I CALLING IN.
SUPPORT AT AT THE. ONE THREE
SEVEN. THREE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE
ALL. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE CARROLL SON AFTER THE
CAL SINCE OF THE MEDICINE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
THREE AND SB EIGHT FIFTY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO THIRTEEN
PLEASE CALL. YEAH I'M SURE BY A
BILL GARCIA ON BEHALF OF THE K.
TEACHERS WITH. REFERRED YOUR
STEP PROCESS BILL FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU. NINETY YOUR LINE IS
pCALLING FROM IT OKAY GOING PART
OF COMMUNITY SAFER EIGHTEEN AND
WE STRONG OPPOSE SB SEVEN
THREE. THANK YOU. NEXT AS LONG.
TWO NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR
SKILLS WE CLIMBED TO NINETY YOU
ARE OPEN. BUT THE CATALAN ON
BEHALF OF THE NATALIE OR ATTACK
B. THIRTY EIGHTY THREE. NOW
FORGOTTEN I TO NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU'RE OPEN TO
NINETY SEVEN. HELLO AND YOUR
EMPLOYEE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY- THEY
SUPPORT- SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
ALLEN M. S. B. TWO EIGHT EIGHT
WE ALSO ON BEHALF OF BLOCKCHAIN
MAYOR BURKE. SUPPORT FOR BOTH
BILLS SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN ALLEN
AND TWO EIGHT EIGHT WIENER
THANK YOU. THREE FIVE PLEASE
CALL. THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'LL COME
BACK THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE THREE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YES HELLO THIS IS
SKIP DOWN TO THE AMERICAN
SUBCONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF CENTER HILL EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE STATE EXCAVATIONS
AND IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
REMODELERS LICENSURE THANK YOU.
HELLO HELLO. YOU'RE FREE
CONTENT SUPPORTER OPPOSITION TO
BILL MMHM. I AM ONE OF LONGTIME
I. CAL CONTAINER OTHER YOU KNOW
CONCERNED ABOUT THE STATE'S
BEEN INNOVATION A LONGTIME
RENTERS LIKE MIKE I HAVE A FULL
SB NINE BOB THANK YOU. MR
OPERATOR. TWENTY THREE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS PATRICIA
TOWARDS BRUNO AND I'M CALLING
FROM THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND I AM
CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU THREE
FORTY TO YOUR OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS IAN DAHLE EMILY BRING
DELIVERY NURSE EVERYTHING THE
END OF MIDWIFERY CARE AND IT
NEVER FREE STUDENT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THREE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THREE FOUR
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
NUMBERED MELANIE CUEVAS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON AT THE NINE OH EIGHT I KIND
OF LIKE HOW YOU THINK YOU.
TWENTY TWO NINETY FORTY ARE
ALSO. HI MY NAME IS FIRST ONE
TO THE NEW THING LINE.
REPRESENTING OF CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL HOW MUCH OF. WHERE OPPOSE
TO BILL ELEVEN TO. NINE ZERO
AND NINE MONTHS THANK YOU.
THREE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARM HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
OKAY GOOD ALL RIGHT ON CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE GOBBLED
UP VALLEY WERE UPON TO AN THE.
ONE TWO. AT THE. NINE OH TWO.
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
RESIDENT DIRECTOR OF THE SANTA
ROSA BIRTH CENTER IN PUTNAM
ACCOUNT OF CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORTING SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. ONE THREE OH THREE YOU
ARE OPEN THREE ZERO THREE. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME MADAM CHAIR YES
I CAM. HI HI THIS IS KATHY
FOGEL I'M CALLING FROM FALL THE
SQUARE- WE ARE AGAINST SB NINE
OH TWO AND SB ONE ONE TWO ZERO-
THERE'S NO PROTECTION FOR HBO'S
THE- WITH THE BILL THANK YOU
STRONG. I HAVE THANK YOU GO
AHEAD THREE OH FIVE. HI MY NAME
IS MOLLY SYLVESTER DIçN THE
CHAIR FOR COMMUNITY FOR THINK
OF ANYTHING I'M A BOARD MEMBER
OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD MARKET
SITUATION AND I'M THE OWNER OF
FAITH IN THE SIX ONE NINE NINE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THREE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
WORRIED LEGALLY AND- FROM THE
ANGELES MESA- AREA AND LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
GOT TO BE ELEVEN TWENTY AND AT
THE NINE OH TWO. THANK YOU
THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS RAY MAIL
ORDER OF LONG BEACH A SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS ALLIANCE
OPPOSES THIS BILL ONE TWENTY
AND SB NINE OH TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE FORTY EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
FORTY EIGHT. MY NAME IS NENAD
DANIELI I'M BIRTH SUPPORT TOOL
AND FREE TIME AT WORK FOR A
CLIENT- I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN BECAUSE OBSTETRICIANS
SHOULD NOT BE GATEKEEPERS FOR
PAYING YEAH THANK YOU. IF WE
CAN JUST FORTY THREE PLEASE GO.
I'M SORRY MEDICARE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THAT'S OKAY I JUST WANNA
REMIND THE CALLER IS THAT THE
ONLY- THING WE NEED TO HEAR IS
YOUR NAME AND THE BILL IN YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU. YOU TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. NO RESPONSE
LINE ALLOWED PEOPLE ON. IN
MIAMI. HOW CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YEAH YEAH I'M WITH- MY NAME'S
GAIL MALL ONE OF THE MORE
PARKING WITHOUT A LAND LINE THE
LOVELY PLAN BROKE. AND I OPPOSE
SB ELEVEN TO ACTION AT THE NINE
TWO AND THE PORT TWELVE NINETY
POINT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS LENA HAPPENED I LIVE IN
AMERICA ARE. AND BALACLAVA
ANALYSTS I AM CALLING- ALONG
WITH THE FACT ONLY A LINE FOR
LOCALLY PLANNED GROWTH. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY ACHEN AND SENATE
BILL NINE OH TWO WIENER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MOVING ALONG THE
LINE- TWO ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LIZ
DONNELLY I'M A CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE I LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I PRACTICE AND WALNUT CREEK
IN ANTIOCH AND- I AM CALLING TO
STRONGLY STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN DODD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE THREE EXCUSE ME THREE
FIFTY FIVE THREE FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TERRY I AM A RESIDENT OF IRVINE
I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF THE
DISCRIMINATORY ANTI SMALL
BUSINESS SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
THANK YOU. LYING TO TWENTY SIX
YOUR OPEN. HI THIS IS A LIBERTY
BELL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
TO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE THERE ABOUT THE KIA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
THREE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TYLER
MONTHLY ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES- WE'RE OPPOSED LAS
AMENDED ON SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
AND IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
THREE EIGHTEEN YOU ARE OPEN
THREE EIGHTEEN. HI MY NAME IS
SHARON MARQUEE I LIVE IN-
OSHANA CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO SEVEN NINE
THREE. THANK YOU I TO NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JENNY PICKLE AND I'M
OPPOSED SB. TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN. THREE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU FOR MY CALL MY NAME
IS ATTORNEY DONE JUSTIN JONES I
AM WORKING WITH THE NO SEVEN
TEN ACTION NEEDING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN
SUSPENSE OF SENATOR ALSO NUMBER
NINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
ONE OF OUR LINE TO SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
LAUREN LEDFORD FROM- THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THREE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TO RECOMMEND
GIVEN THE FACT THAT
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATOR
RUBIO'S SB SIX ONE FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THREE TWENTY ONE
YOU ARE OPEN. THREE TWENTY ONE.
I WILL GO TO THREE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO HELLO
THIS IS DAVID FROM MANTA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION PREPARED
HOW THAT THE ARE REALLY UPSET
WITH OFFER THEM I HOPE THAT THE
FOURTEENTH. THREE SIX FIVE
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MEDICARE MEMBERS
RIGHT DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA A BILL TORREY
SURGERY ASSOCIATION OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED ON S. B. TWO
SEVEN FIVE BY DR PAM AND ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN BY MR MANI AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PHYSICIAN PRACTICES
ASSOCIATION ALSO STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OVER BACK
TO LINE THREE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TAYLOR
I'D BE PRESIDENT PRO TEM THE
WEST TO BE LIKE TO SEE. AND I
URGE THE COMMITTEE PLEASED TO
PUT THREE HOUSING BILLS IN THE
SUSPENSE FILE WHICH ARE
FISCALLY IRRESPONSIBLE OKAY
THINK IT LANDED FIFTY FOUR
BILLION THANK YOU THE ONLY
THING THAT WE'RE TAKING. THE
ONLY THING WE ARE TAKING AT
THIS POINT IS YOUR NAME THE
BILL AND WHAT DO YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE IT ANYTHING ELSE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO CUT OFF THANK
YOU. MOVING ALONG WITH OVER ONE
THREE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS BRIAN COOK THE END
OF THE MOST STRONGLY OPPOSEDANTI COMMUNITY HRT INTEREST
BILL SB. NINE THANK YOU I'VE
THREE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JOSH
WILL BORE I AM A CONSUMER AND
TOBACCO HARM REDUCTION ADVOCATE
IN CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THREE SEVENTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA YOU'LL
BE CONVENIENT ALLIANCE
REPRESENTING OVER HALF OF THE
GAS STATIONS AND CONVENIENCE
STORES IN THE STATE THAT SEVEN
NINETY THREE THANKS. THREE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN AIM WITH LOS ALTOS CITY
COUNCIL WHAT'S NEXT THE NINE
CAMPAIGN I'M A PRODUCTIVE SB
NINE NINE FIVE. SB. ELEVEN
TWENTY SB NINE NOW TO THANK YOU.
THREE SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS KAYLA
CHRISTIAN AND ON BEHALF OF
FOURTEEN HUNDRED PLUS RETAIL
MEMBER OF AMERICAN PETROLEUM
AND CONVENIENCE ASSOCIATION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THREE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
CAROL MORE- OPPOSED ELEVEN
TWENTY NINE OH TWO THANK YOU.
THREE EIGHTY THREE ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS STEVEN
RESNICK A PRESIDENT OF THE WEST
WOULD HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING- TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED HOMEOWNERS IN THE
WESTWOOD AREA OF LOS ANGELES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. SB ELEVEN
TWENTY AND S. B. NINE OH TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THREE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AT. THREE
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. MOVING ALONG
WE WILL GO TO THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DAVE WILLIAMS
I'M A LICENSED PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR IN THE CONSTITUENT
ASSEMBLY MAN TYLER DEEP I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON SB
NINE AWAIT ALEXIS AMENDED TO
ENSURE THAT LICENSED PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO OBTAIN A SECOND LARGEST YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
STEVEN SCHARF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS IN CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST THE
DISPLACEMENT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO AT
ELEVEN TWENTY ACTIVE AND AT THE
NINE OH TWO WIENER. THANK YOU
AND WILL ALIGN THREE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT WIENER
AND AT THE SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
ALLEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THREE NINETY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS PARRIS MALOOF
VERY I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I AM CALLING TO
SUPPORT. SENATE BILL TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN AND URGENT I VOTE
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU. I
WILL GO TO THREE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE NINE. HI
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
ON VALERIE KEEGAN STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN TWENTY AND SB
NINE OH TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THREE NINETY SEVEN YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER
EMILY DOLL IN STRONG SUPPORT-
SB ONE TWO THREE SEVEN DOLLARS
THANK YOU. THREE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHRISTIANA
DEMANDED ON BEHALF OF BILL
SPONSOR ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVEA
BUT THAT THE COURT SENATOR
MONNING SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN.
EXCELLENT NEXT IS ONE FOUR
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD FOUR
ZERO ZERO. GOOD AFTER GOOD
MORNING RATHER I TERM MEMBERS
LOSE MONDAY WITH CALIFORNIA
YIMBY HERE TO URGE SUPPORT FOR
AT THE NINE OH TWO SB NINE NINE
FIVE AND AT ELEVEN TWENTY THANK
YOU. ONE FOUR ZERO FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHERINE
HI LIKE I'M A NURSE MIDWIFERY-
PRACTITIONER FOR THE LAST
THIRTY PLUS YEARS- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. FOURTEEN YOU
ARE OPEN. FOR FOURTEEN. YEAH
TOM AND NANCY WHAT'S YOUR
MEMBER UNITED- CALTRANS TENANTS
OPPOSING SB NINE COMPLETELY
UNFAIR AND THE PEOPLE THAT
LIVED THERE FOR MANY YEARS-
WITH THE EXPECTATION WHICH
THEY'RE NOW TRYING TO CHANGE.
LINE FOR TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO TWENTY THREE YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
I CAN HEAR YOU. HEY CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. HI MY NAME IS
MERRY WHO ASK I'M SPEAKING FROM
MY MISTAKE CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE
TO VOICE MY STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL ONE ONE TWO ZERO
AND I KNOW TO. AND THESE L.
WELL PROVIDE. HI MY- WE DON'T
WE'RE NOT TAKING TESTS ON THE
BILLS WE THE PEOPLE SIMPLY
STATE THEIR NAME AND POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL
ALIGN FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS FOR A CALL AND THE NURSE
MIDWIFE I AM STRONGLY URGING
YOU TO VOTE YES ON AT THE WHITE
Q. THREE SEVEN THANK YOUNG
THANK YOUNG.
THE OPERATOR. DO
WE STILL HAVE THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE. ONCE I GET THE
OPERATORS WITH THE PARTICIPANTS
WE JUST HAVE A COUPLE MORE
QUEUING UP OKAY. THERE WE GOT
IT AND WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY.
FOUR THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS THE LIMIT OF A GARY
I'M A CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE
AND DIRECTOR OF WOMEN'S HEALTH
AT AYE SKINNER HELP. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU I'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
ANOTHER ONES WITH AN OPERATOR.
A LINE. ONE FOUR THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD FOR THIRTY
THREE. JULIE SNYDER THE HALF OF
THE DAY BERGEN HERE ARE PROUD
TO BE SPONSORS- SB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE BY SENATOR WIENER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE'RE WELL
ALIGNED FOR THIRTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR SIX
FOUR THREE SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU-
MY NAME IS BRENDA MARTINEZ AND
I AM- RESIDENT DID BOYLE
HEIGHTS IN CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO
THE BOARD MEMBER OF BOYLE
HEIGHTS NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL
AND I'LL THE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE ATKINS WINNER BILL. WAY TO
THE IS NINE OF. NINE OH TWO
ELEVEN. AND SB NINE NINE FIVE
BUT I STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE S.
B. TWELVE NINETY NINE THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. AND THEN I'M
SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU- I AM GLAD TO
HAVE GOTTEN THROUGH THAT AND
WITH THAT WE CONCLUDE THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING UNTIL
THURSDAY.